over the past years cbs news has
reported extensively on sexual assault
in the u.s military after our reports
aired the pentagon made fighting this
epidemic a priority
now after a two-year cbs news
investigation reveals a second crisis it
is domestic violence we found gaps in
the process of reporting abuse across
all military branches
service members military spouses and
partners who reported abuse said that
the military failed to protect them
their survivors told us a problem is
pervasive and they feel it is overlooked
cbs evening news anchor and managing
editor nora o'donnell joins us at the
table nora it's really good to see you
you know but it's so sorry to hear this
because i know this must have been
difficult for them to speak up but very
glad they did yeah good morning to all
of you and thanks for having us and
letting us report on this very important
story because the numbers are staggering
roughly 100 000 incidents of domestic
abuse have been reported to the military
since 2015 the pentagon hasn't kept
track of how many of those reports
involve violence so it's actually
impossible to know the full scope of
this problem what we do know is that
these are serious crimes and some
survivors told us they felt they were in
more danger after they reported them
there's no doubt in my mind he was going
to kill me
in 2019 retired master sergeant erica
johnson told air force leaders she was
being physically and sexually assaulted
by someone she was in an intimate
relationship with domestic violence is
you know this unspoken bad word bad
phrase
nobody wants to talk about it cbs news
spoke with nearly 40 survivors who like
erica reported abuse to the military and
i think in the military specifically
it's even more this forgotten crisis
because there's this veil of a uniform
according to department of defense
policy commanders are required to tell
victims about resources send reports to
law enforcement for investigation and
ensure military offenders are held
accountable does the military provide
enough support
to domestic violence survivors no no
after erica reported she had been raped
and beaten the air force's office of
special investigations looked into her
claims how did they handle your case
initially it seemed like they were
taking me seriously he checked his
military weapon out and threatened me
with it
and then
as things went on they just got really
dismissive
they wouldn't accept evidence for me
they didn't use my statements
it just didn't make any sense army major
leah olszewski has become a champion for
survivors she reported being physically
assaulted to the air force
i also told them that i had been
strangulated
he had also
threatened to break my neck
bust my front teeth out
in 2019 leah told her story before
congress she says it changed nothing so
she's sharing her story again
you had a miscarriage i did yes
and do you believe that was the result
of the domestic violence yes he kicked
me in the stomach and i flew off the bed
into the closet doors and then he took
the comforter and walked off like
nothing had happened
it's really hard to hear and i'm just
really sorry
thank you
it is hard to hear
like leah liz knight was also expecting
a child when she says she was abused in
2018 just weeks after she'd given birth
in south korea she called army police
for the first time
he had put hands on me and was physical
and why was that the moment that you
called the police it was my breaking
point i had a five-week-old infant i
felt like i needed to protect myself and
my son
military police investigated and found
probable cause to charge the alleged
perpetrator with assault it was up to
his commander to decide the consequences
his commander only issued a local letter
of reprimand that's right so
the minute he left south korea where it
happened it was wiped clean from his
record as if it never happened
and do you think that was enough
absolutely not the soldier is an asset
they need him they have spent a lot of
money to train him and to do his job and
who am i
as long as i'm removed and i'm not part
of the problem
then they have their soldier when i was
speaking to the prosecutor you know he
point blank told me you know it might
not be in the best interest of the air
force to pursue this or hold him
accountable
erica hasn't received a copy of the air
force's investigative report but she was
told based on the findings the commander
decided to take no action i felt so
betrayed by the air force you feel the
military betrayed you it was severe
betrayal do each of you feel that way
[Music]
yes the trade yes in the course of our
investigation we tried to find out just
how widespread the problem is the
military is supposed to track
disciplinary actions taken by commanders
in domestic violence cases
but a report from the government
accountability office from earlier this
year revealed the pentagon hasn't kept
comprehensive data on those numbers
even though it's been a legal
requirement since 1999.
did any of your cases go to a court
martial
no
two of the alleged offenders are still
serving and one retired honorably for
these survivors the apparent lack of
accountability has led to a very real
sense of fear
he's going to do this to someone else
if it's not someone in the military a
spouse
it's going to be somebody in the
community the next person is going to
kill
there's no doubt in my mind and he knows
how to get away with it he's told me as
much
it took a lot of courage for leah liz
and erica to share their stories with us
we should note that one of defense
secretary lloyd austin's early accident
office was creating an independent
review commission to examine the issue
of sexual assault in the military and in
june that commission recommended taking
decisions to prosecute both sexual
assault and domestic violence cases away
from commanders the secretary agreed
with that recommendation so that is some
movement forward that is good i was
struck by the woman's phrase where she
said the veil of the uniform really
stood out to me and one woman who was
told might not be an asset to report it
right now
it's so disturbing nora to hear their
stories what is the pentagon saying what
is their response to your well we spoke
with a senior defense official who's to
acknowledge this is a silent epidemic
and that official called it
heartbreaking unacceptable maddening the
defense secretary issued a statement to
us saying this is an issue that plagues
our ranks and fundamentally impacts our
combat readiness so they acknowledge it
and we're actually going to post
secretary austin's full statement to us
on our website removing commanders from
these decisions is part of the solution
but real change will require more what
needs to happen congress right congress
has to act on this they there are
members of both parties that think it
should be taken away from the commanders
that bill in the annual defense spending
bill is before congress they need to do
a full vote on it and then that would
create the change that so many survivors
and victims want in order to address
this but i do think you know there is
leadership at the top of the pentagon on
this let's see what actually changes
this is really one of the hardest
stories i have ever covered in my entire
career yeah you've been all on top of
this though for a very long time thank
you so much for coming on our first day
and it's stories like that that we're
planning to do in the seven years yeah
really thank you hard reporting and and
thank you guys for having me it's a
beautiful set and good to see all of you
thank you pretty soon the pentagon will
get the word norah o'donnell on the
phone and it'll be uh they'll be hiding
under their desk but maybe you'll get
something
which will change what happened already
burning up the phone form will come
thank you norah